UML supports a couple of special transitions that you can take advantage of,
each indicated by a keyword. So,
here's a two state machine. The transition from the active state to idle state.
the, transition is labeled after 2 seconds. Okay? So you can assume
that there's a timer here that if you're in the active state 2 seconds later,
you'll make the transition to the idle state. Similarly, the idle state has
a self transition, okay? That's labeled when we key, the keyword when and
then a particular clock time that the system
waits until that particular clock time happens before making the transition.
We can put this example in a slightly larger context of to ill, to illustrate
one other feature of, state charts. So, we have the self transition on idle and
we have some, normal, transitions labeled by events in the rest of the diagram.
But the transition between idle and tracking, okay? Involves an action, okay?
That action is invocating a method, invoking a method, and the method
has a parameter p, that is you can pass information in the action calls.
Similarly, on the transition itself, the event that led to the transition has
an argument p. So, what we're doing here is we're passing on the information.
That came in on the event to some kind of method call so
it can presumably be processed in the tracking state